hi this is fresh talker in this video
we're going to discuss a math puzzler
about optimizing the area that offense
encloses so imagine you have a hundred
units of fencing we'll think about this
as wire fencing and draw it as a
straight line the puzzle is how can you
box off the largest area possible that's
next to a river so specifically you want
to enclose an area which is three sides
of a rectangle and what's between that
and the river should be the largest area
possible so one way you could divide up
the hundred units of fencing is to have
ten ten for the length and eighty for
the width and that will give you an area
of 800 so the puzzle is to box off the
largest area possible so give it a try
and when you're ready you can keep
watching for the solution all right so
the elegant solution will be using
geometry but I'm going to present the
calculus solution first so the geometry
of the situation is we have a rectangle
of which one side is the river and we
have two sides that are the length and
one side which is the width so we want
to maximize the area which is the length
times the width the amount of fencing
will be two times L plus W and that
needs to be equal to 100 so we can
rearrange that equation to say the width
of the fence has to be 100 minus 2l
substituting that into our area formula
we have the area is 100 L minus 2l
squared we can optimize the area as a
function of L by taking the derivative
with respect to L and setting that equal
to 0 so we get 100 minus 4 l equals 0
we'll solve this for l equals 25 and
then we'll solve the W X equal 100 minus
2l which is therefore 50 so the largest
area we can enclose is 25 times 50 which
is 1,250
so this is a very good and standard way
to solve the problem but now I'm going
to show you a more creative way and an
elegant solution it requires a little
more in terms of logic but it's
definitely worth knowing so let's think
about instead of having the river let's
just think about a rectangle and we want
to solve the problem what's the largest
rectangle for a given perimeter the
perimeter of a rectangle is 2 times the
length plus 2 times the width and the
area is the length times the width so
here's our solution we're going to
imagine drawing the square where the two
sides are equal so we take a little bit
from the longer side and we add that to
the shorter side so the two sides are
equal now because we've removed this one
the same distance from one side that
we've added to the other the perimeter
is the same but now when you look at the
area you're going to gain this large
rectangle and you might lose that other
rectangle so the area is actually larger
by a factor of x squared so what this
shows is that the square is actually the
largest rectangle you can have for a
given perimeter because if you have a
rectangle that's not a square you can
always make it a square and that'll be
the largest area you can have alright so
how does that information help us solve
the original problem what we'll do is
we'll imagine flipping a mirror image of
this boxed off area over to the other
side of the river because if we optimize
the side on one side of the river we
must optimize the sum over both sides
that's reflected so this rectangle has a
width of W and a length of 2 out in
order to box off the largest area this
figure must be a square so the width has
to be equal to 2 times the length and we
know the perimeter is 2 L plus W equals
100 so we can easily solve that the
length is equal to 25 and the width is
50 so the area is 1250
so that's the geometric solution and
it's quite elegant did you solve the
puzzle I hope you liked this video
please subscribe to my channel you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on Twitter at pressure Locker
and you can get my books listed on my
website